good evening my name is Katie Batchelder
and I am a freshman from Hillsdale
Michigan it is my privilege to introduce
you our speaker for this evening dr.
Burton for Folsom junior studied at
Centre College before receiving his BA
from Indiana University dr. Folsom holds
a master's degree from the University of
Nebraska and a PhD from the University
of Pittsburgh he is taught at Murray
State University Northwood University
and currently holds the Charles Cline
chair in history and management at
Hillsdale College he also worked for
several years at the Mackinac Center for
Public Policy and the center for the
American idea he is currently a guest
scholar at the Heritage Foundation
senior historian at the foundation for
economic education and writes a
quarterly column for the freeman his
articles have appeared in The Wall
Street Journal Business History Review
investor's business daily and The
Washington Times among others he has
made numerous radio and television
appearances including the Glenn Beck
show Fox & Friends and c-span he has
published six books including myth of
the robber barons and New Deal or rajul
how FDR's economic legacy has damaged
America please join me in welcoming dr.
Folsom
thank you very much thank you Katie and
thanks to dr. Colt off and my colleagues
in the history department thank you to
Tim Kaspar and Doug Jeffery for inviting
me to this CCA which is entitled FDR and
the New Deal lovefest
at least that's what its entitled so far
actually I think it's delightful to get
different points of view on a subject
that is am important is this subject and
especially admire the civility and the
courteous behavior that we always show
at Hillsdale College to our guests
whether we agree with the guests and
speakers or not I've learned my lessons
actually on civility from FDR himself
Franklin Roosevelt was kind of a
practiced in the art of civility because
he would hold these cabinet meetings or
conferences and often he would be in a
situation where people would say do you
like this idea
or do you like this person to be
promoted or to hold a particular
position and Roosevelt yet he didn't
want to be a position say no this guy's
a jerk because then somebody surely
would take it out of that meeting and go
tell the guy that that's what Roosevelt
said right and so I mean you didn't you
don't want anything like that so he
didn't want to make any negative
comments that might be taken and Andry
quoted later and so Roosevelt had a way
when he would be in these kinds of
meetings if anybody would make a
suggestion you know we did would you do
you think this person ought to be
promoted to this position if he didn't
think so or didn't like him he would
just do this
and that pretty much got the message of
cross can conveyed what he was thinking
and that way he didn't have to be have
anybody say that he'd said anything so
in that tradition regarding some of the
things that have been said in the New
Deal CCA so far my attitude a little bit
is this
but don't quote me on you know it is fun
to tell you that we can laugh about
ideas on something this important this
is one of the most important times in
American history the ideas that come out
of the New Deal are absolutely exciting
absolutely important to study and here
at Hillsdale College we bring in both
sides there are campuses all over
America that if they would have a
similar event such as this or any other
kind of event it would be one totally
dominated by political correctness they
would not have someone from the other
side in I have occasionally been invited
to some of these to be the one person
presenting the free market perspective
and I can say this as I was as I was
watching the events as they've taken
place today never have I been treated as
well on those campuses all around
America is our campus here at Hillsdale
treats people who come in here who may
not be expressing ideas that the
audience would be completely in
agreement with and I like that when I
was speaking for example one recently at
UCLA you know a very liberal campus and
the audience you know they had a rough
look to them they didn't have suits and
ties and all of this in name cards and
always and so I I was trying to pump
myself up backstage you know you could
do it
the person who is organizing the event
came up to me and introduced me to
Manuel here you know this big guy and he
said Manuel
he's your bodyguard and he was with me
the entire event until the time I left
and got in a cab to leave I had a
bodyguard with me speaking on that
campus now at Hillsdale College needless
to say I don't need a bodyguard
well except at the end of the semester
when I'm delivering my grades different
it's a central hall and then sometimes I
might need one but it's a much more
civil atmosphere in Hillsdale College
and for that I appreciate you know
getting into this subject of the New
Deal and the ideas which we're talking
about I'd like to make two points right
off and the first point is if when we
talk about the Great Depression one of
the points we need to get straight right
off is that the government was heavily
responsible for the damage that created
the Great Depression now some of that
our speakers have already gotten into
with the problems with the Federal
Reserve with raising interest rates and
the disappearance of 1/4 to 1/3 of our
money supply was very damaging Milton
Friedman of course eventually winning
the Nobel Prize and largely for his work
on the Great Depression and the Federal
Reserve and the problems that it caused
also another problem was the
smoot-hawley Tariff we had the highest
tariffs in United States history that
was passed in 1930 and this tariff
raised prices heavily on over a thousand
items and we had significant tariffs on
over 3,200 items and the problem that
creates is this if we're going to charge
say say if Swiss watches are going to be
four dollars and if we're going to tell
the Swiss because that's their major
export hey we won't buy your watches
except we'll pay you the four and then
we'll put a four dollar tariff on those
watches so they'll cost eight dollars
over here then we're not buying as many
and so we just closed off our our
export-import market and then
Switzerland in turn and acts retaliatory
tariffs and they
used to buy our products and if you look
at the auto industry for example we were
selling five million cars mostly out of
Detroit here in Michigan in in 1929 and
that was down to 1.5 million in 1933 now
there were a variety of things involved
with that but the smoot-hawley Tariff
was a critical factor in that
so the tariff is a factor in causing the
Great Depression and also Herbert Hoover
then proceeded to enact with Congress's
cooperation of course the highest
peacetime set of taxes income tax rates
excise taxes in US history and so that
is going to make it so investors are
going to have are not going to have
incentives to invest they're gonna have
incentives to retreat from investment to
put their money into tax-exempt bonds
foreign investments this sort of thing
and you see the economy contracting and
we do indeed see the rate that has been
mentioned by some of our speakers of
twenty five percent unemployment which
we had in 1932 in 1933 so my first point
is that government was heavily involved
in the causing of the Great Depression
that's first point write-off in our
second point that needs to be made is
that if we're going to talk about the
New Deal and we're going to look at was
the New Deal successful to some extent
and our main measurement is going to be
unemployment did to the extent that were
resolving the unemployment problem then
we have to say the New Deal was a
failure the New Deal was a failure up
until the time of the Great Depression
we had never in our history had
unemployment higher than seventeen
percent that was the worst rate we'd
ever had in US history
toward the end of Roosevelt's second
term he could no longer really blame
Hoover at that point
in 1939 toward the end of his second
term unemployment in April was twenty
point seven percent roughly twenty one
percent four points higher ten years
after the Great Depression had started
and in the Roosevelt seventh year in the
White House four points higher than had
ever been in the history of the United
States and this was an absolute disaster
I begin the book my book new dealer
audio with this quotation from his
Secretary of Treasury Henry Morgenthau
who's just pulling his air Rome
organized a great friend of Roosevelt
the two of them they'd been friends for
decades Roosevelt put Morgenthau into
the Treasury Department because he
wanted a friend there and Morgenthau had
been active in the political camp
political campaigns of Franklin
Roosevelt their two wives were both
named Eleanor and Morgenthau and
Roosevelt they'd sometimes passed notes
back to one another during cabinet
meetings they would have lunch regularly
together
Eleanor one time said Henry Morgenthau
was one of the two people who could tell
Franklin Roosevelt to his face he was
wrong and get away with it and Henry
Morgenthau is saying this right after
the unemployment statistics come in at
almost 21% in 1939 he says and if this
is a commentary on the New Deal
we have tried spending money we are
spending more than we have ever spent
before and it does not work and I have
just one interest and if I am wrong
somebody else can have my job I want to
see this country prosperous I want to
see people get a job I want to see
people get enough to eat we have never
made good on our promises I say after
eight years of this administration we
have just as much unemployment as when
we started and an enormous debt
to boot which is true we had doubled the
national debt in Roosevelt's years in
office at that point into his seventh
year and what I'm saying is this
we have 21% unemployment four points
higher than it had ever been in United
States history before the Great
Depression and we had doubled the
national debt and that's our recovery
program measured by unemployment and
getting out of the Great Depression the
New Deal was a colossal failure
now I it sure it suggests government
solutions do not work well it suggests
that the ideas of John Maynard Keynes do
not work well he had written his book
the general theory of employment
interest and money he'd even had an
interview with Franklin Roosevelt and he
came to the conclusion that we needed to
spend lots of money on public works they
called it aggregate demand management
that you would increase the amount of
government spending of course you have
to tax people to do often to get those
dollars or go into debt and then you'd
spend that and it would that you'd have
a multiplier effect and then you would
be able to get out of a depression or a
recession through that now I say this is
what Keynes seems to be saying because
if you read Keynes you quickly learn
that there's Keynesian English and
there's a militia English I'm trying to
summarize Keynes
let me quote him on unemployment quote
men are and this is from his book men
are involuntarily unemployed if in the
event of a small rise in the price of
wage goods relative to the money wage
both the aggregate supply of labor
willing to work for the current money
wage and the aggregate demand for it at
that wage would be greater than the
existing volume of unemployment
hey the interpretation that was given to
his writings was that we needed to
invest and we needed to invest heavily
public works this sort of thing Keynes
himself said boy if we pulled all the
houses down in South London and then
rebuilt a medical lots of people to work
well let's look at how we applied some
of these ideas they were in the air
Keynes wasn't the only one who had them
this is part of the progressive impulse
of the early 1900's as it had evolved by
the 1930s and we let's look at some of
these programs we've been reluctant to
discuss some of them in a little bit of
detail we have the triple a for farmers
the Agricultural Adjustment Act well
that's an interesting law what we're
gonna do here because we have an
overproduction of farm products and
farmers have low wages so the ideas that
we come up with and this is a battle of
ideas is the idea is that we pay farmers
not to produce now if we pay farmers not
to produce and take part of their land
out of circulation in return then then
the the supply will be lower because
we're taking land out of circulation and
the farmers will have more money because
we're paying them not to produce we also
have a parity system to help raise the
price of their crops but the fundamental
idea will pay them not to produce and
then that will help alleviate the farm
crisis
I'm sorry to have to say this only an
academic could come up with an idea
professor John Dee black economist to
Harvard
that was his brainchild and there were
others involved too and it just was such
a wonderful idea we'll pay people not to
produce and we it's interesting to look
because this is again the progressive
impulse the optimism that we can solve
the problems of humankind and here's how
you first of all have a deal ok we're
gonna let them take a quarter of their
land out of circulation will pay them
roughly $10 an acre that which would be
$100 an acre so today for each acre of
land they take out of circulation and
then we and them and then we won't have
as much over overproduction well the
first thing we find out is that farmers
once you tell them to do that and they
agree to do it some of them do it and
some don't I mean they all take the
money they all agree to that it's just
some relief maybe don't take their land
out of circulation so we have to send
inspectors with measuring equipment to
go by and measure all of their land to
make sure they're really taking 1/4 of
it out of circulation and then we
discover I hate to say this to the ears
of Hillsdale students some of the
farmers bribed the inspectors
and you weren't gonna fool our AG
department and so we had to send
inspectors by to inspect the inspectors
we figured the cost of double bribing
would be too high and therefore it would
make them honest you know this is my
first year when I got out of graduate
school I was a new professor I was
teaching at us at a regional campus in
Kentucky and there were a lot of old
Southern gentlemen on the faculty it was
my first year and I wanted to get in
good with them because I was hoping to
get tenure and I'm not a southerner and
I was wanting to get in good with him
and one of the the chairmen of the
tenure committee was going to go to a
conference and I was asked if I'd like
to just come along and I thought hey
this is a real opportunity you know and
I came along and I thought maybe I could
I didn't even know if he knew my name
you know at least I can get to know him
maybe and so we were talking and he he
was asking me what I had done in my life
I asked him what he had done in his life
and he well when I was in college I
worked as an inspector for the triple-a
and I just burnt
did you take any bribes he may have
thought I was really anxious for tenure
I think that may have been rights trying
to find out but you know I just blurted
it out and he was funny he says know the
best offer I had was a new set of tires
anything I really mad because I had a
friend and he got all the good bribes
well we go through the inspectors who
are coming on the land here and that
doesn't work real well so then we have a
bright idea to do aerial photography so
we're gonna do aerial photography of all
of this land to make sure they've taken
the land out of circulation so now look
at this we've got inspectors inspectors
inspecting the inspectors aerial
photographs to make sure we take all of
this land out of circulation we take it
out of circulation and sure enough in
1935 two years later we have crop
shortages the United States has to
import 34 million bushels of corn in
1935 and of course we had our own global
warming back then in the Midwest and
then the cooling and then warming and so
we didn't have good crops in the Midwest
and 34 million bushels of corn we had to
import 13 million bushels of wheat and
but it was even in the south this was
going on we imported 36 million pounds
of cotton what I'm telling you is we're
going on to the end of the south on the
cotton plantations pain the people on
those plantations not to produce and
then turning around and paying for
imports high-priced imports from
foreigners to make up the difference and
that's our farm policy we could go on to
the National Recovery Act the NRA I
don't want to talk too much about that
IIIi thought professor Brinkley was
right he it was a disaster
if we got businessmen together and said
why don't you set the prices you want to
charge for your products you think you
ought to charge and then we'll make
those prices legally binding and just to
make sure anybody who sells below that
we'll send them to jail and so I mean
there's a section of my book dealing
with these people who went to jail and
it's really a very set for giving
discounts to customers one of them Jacob
majid was a tailor and he the NRA code
for pressing a pair of pants was 40
cents and his shop was off of Main
Street in Jersey City New Jersey so see
he couldn't he couldn't get people to
come to his shop if he charged what
everybody else was charging the 40 cent
rate so he was giving discounts at 35
cents to press a pair of pants so that
they walk a few blocks to get to his
shop well the NRA closed him down sent
him to jail and we got a variety of
comments on this he's in jail and he
says well he says you can't tell me how
to run my business well they did tell
him how to run it they put him in jail I
like this though the Washington Post
said this it didn't matter the
Washington Post said if maguet had to
charge less than the bright shiny tailor
shop up the street if he wanted to
continue to exist the law said he
couldn't and I like this for a parallel
the New York Herald Tribune said for a
parallel it is necessary to go to the
fascist or communist states of Europe
and we finally had the Supreme Court
strike down the NRA National Recovery
Act in 1935 and it's going to be off the
books but that was the plan for business
and we have those NRA papers in the
Library of Congress and some day you
know Hillsdale where we are represented
as you know now in Washington DC I think
it would be fun to have some students do
some papers right out of those original
archives and see what else can be found
on the National Recovery Act let's look
at the big prop the pump priming Act the
WPA
one was Works Progress Administration
you build roads you build bridges you
build airports you build schools doesn't
this sounds good in theory doesn't you
have unemployed people and you put them
to work building those roads and schools
a lot of roads and you you have that
then that will reduce unemployment is
the idea but what we got we have to
realize is four point eight billion
dollars which doesn't seem like a lot
now when trillion is the only word that
seems meaningful but four point eight
billion was the largest investment in a
domestic program that we had ever had in
the United States before like this it
was four billion eight hundred thousand
or four billion eight hundred million
dollars and so what this does is it
gives Roosevelt this humongous pile of
cash and he ends up because he has
tremendous control over it
divvying it up into areas that he wants
to capture the votes in that are
politically expedient who have
congressmen or senators in those
districts who will do what he says and
so this makes it an incredible program
to subsidize much of the New Deal I have
some quotations just gives you a flavor
here of how a lot of Democrats were
looking at the WPA V G Copeland the
Democratic County chairman of Indiana
said this quote what I think will help
is to change the WPA management from top
to bottom put men in there who are in
favor of using these democratic projects
to make votes for the Democratic Party
that is the heart of a lot of the New
Deal
James Doherty the New Hampshire
Democratic read quote it is my personal
belief that to the victor belongs the
spoils and that Democrats should be
holding most of those wpa positions so
that we might strengthen our fences for
the 1940 election I like one WPA
director in New Jersey I have in my book
a corrupt but candid man
answered his telephone quote Democratic
headquarters so you have the chairman of
the WPA and Serena's phone Democratic
headquarters they have a file in the
National Archives on WPA slash political
corruption and it's huge in its bi-state
and if you look at that you you find
things like this
Frank towie of New Jersey announced at a
democratic rally in Newark New Jersey
quote in this county there are 18,000
people on the WPA with an average of
three people in a family you have 54,000
potential Democratic votes can anyone
beat that if it is properly mobilized do
you see here how Franklin Roosevelt is
winning elections see one of the
problems in analyzing the New Deal is
the program programs didn't work but the
fallback position of Roosevelt's
defenders often as well yes but he must
have given people hope hope and change
and and we know that because he was
winning elections and winning on Big C
in other words he would have his
fireside chats and people would listen
and he would give them hope and look at
these jobs and these people working on
these jobs so he was trying he was doing
his best and you have to therefore give
him credit for that
but what you have to see is that this
money which you can understand why the
founders were so specific in article 1
section 8 not letting all of these
programs be part of the federal
government to federalize all this is to
put into the hands of a president a huge
political war chest it's interesting to
listen to the these are Democrats who
voted for Roosevelt these are his
friends who are saying this I don't
quote as enemies because at Hillsdale
College we believe in G and P G lectures
and so I'm quoting his friends and
here's what his friends say the
Democratic senator from Virginia Carter
glass says this the 1936 elections would
have been much closer had my party
not had a four billion eight hundred
million dollar relief bill as campaign
fodder in other words you target
congressional districts you target key
states Pennsylvania was a swing state
very important the Democrats had not
carried it in decades and decades
Roosevelt wanted it lots of wpa money
into Pennsylvania you target the key
states you tell the people running as
Democrats to mention all the programs
that are coming into the states and then
you say if you would like this to
continue vote for Roosevelt in both the
Democratic ticket and as one Republican
said after the election apparently you
can't beat Santa Claus and that's what
happened in the 1936 election a
tremendous victory for Roosevelt and I
don't mean it was just the WPA there are
a whole lot of programs that just
sometimes get missed in the textbook for
example how many have heard of the
Silver Purchase Act you know a few yeah
we were busy Lee purchasing silver it
was a subsidy to six western states to
get their votes which Roosevelt did what
you do is the normal price of silver
which is a main industry in those
western states it was roughly the market
price was about 40 cents an ounce the
Silver Purchase Act which Roosevelt
signed would pay silver miners sixty
four and a half cents an ounce say in
order to it pay him almost 50 percent
more than the market value of silver
it's so the law of unintended
consequences comes in and there's a huge
outpouring of silver in the West in fact
it wasn't just in the West we had people
in Mexico smuggling silver across the
border
yet because you buy it at 40 and you can
sell it at 64 and a half so we had
issues of silver imports coming in and
according to the rule
so the Silver Purchase Act you had you
couldn't get rid of it I mean sure you
were making some silver for industrial
uses but this had to be stockpiled after
eight years of stockpiling silver we had
forty two thousand tons of silver
according to that act the federal
government had I mean I just don't know
what kind of shape this is in I mean
it's almost like the Tower of Babel you
know going up there we're like where God
says don't do this don't do this as it
goes up up up
let me try everybody close your eyes
from it everybody close your eyes I get
it Amelia makes you wrap their knuckles
if they're not closing don't fall asleep
on me promise that pleasure he imagine
try to imagine a mountain of 42,000 tons
of silver imagine what it looks like
42,000 tons
okay I had you do that because so much
of the defenders of Roosevelt approach
the problem this way they say think of
it this way lots of people having jobs
and they're working on the jobs and he's
trying to get us out of the Great
Depression well one way to get around to
say yeah look at the tax dollars going
out of a lot of people's wallets into
those jobs which are doing things like
piling 42,000 tons of silver into a big
pile
I hope someone here you know when you
write your essays on the CCA draw the
most imaginative diagram of 42,000 tons
of silver I listen I'll give a copy of
my book to the most imaginative drawing
a 42,000 tons of silver how that looks
like and how that was so what you have
to have a vision here is money see
dollars going out of the wallets of all
everybody all over the country flowing
over there into the western states and
then see in Washington 42,000 amount of
42,000 tons of silver which constitutes
2% almost 2% of the entire national debt
oh it's 2 percent our entire national
debt in a big mountain of silver which
we're not allowed to get rid of and this
is what was supposed to get us out of
the Great Depression it didn't do it
there's no silver lining in that cloud
you know some of this is tragic because
in World War two we finally got to spend
the silver because I mean we had to for
industrial and then Roosevelt was
worried he wouldn't be able to carry
those western states and we some of this
is very tragic because that's when we
began rounding up the Japanese 110,000
Japanese once you begin to centralize
power and increase it in the state then
we get the rounding up of Japanese which
is very popular with a lot of the same
people who are now mad because you
you're using up their silver now they're
happy because they've got the Japanese
out of the circulation it's sad to read
Eric Muller and his book recent book
American Inquisition documents how
Roosevelt knew in 1942 1943
those Japanese were loyal but many of
them were fighting overseas in a very
loyal way to the United States but he
would not let them out because he said
if I they come out in the 1944 election
which I plan to run for a fourth term
what will happen is that they'll be mad
at us in those western states and that
becomes a reason you have to see the
politics of all of this the politics of
federal programs centralizing power the
use of those programs to in effect
bribe or buy votes then win reelection
and change American politics forever
because the other side land and poorer
blend and running against Roosevelt said
oh this Triple A is terrible and then
they said Roosevelt said well what are
you gonna do you know a lot of farmers
said you're gonna take our subsidy away
no no no I will take your subsidy away
he's I'll manage it better so what you
get a choice in thirty Six's do you vote
for the guy who gave you your subsidy or
the guy who alleges that he will manage
it better and that's been part of the
dilemma of the Republican Party ever
since how to respond to that this has to
be paid for with taxes you almost never
see a New Deal book that discusses taxes
it has to be discussed if you're gonna
discuss the programs and you're gonna
you're going to talk about those and
some were better than others and some
were worse than others then you've got
to talk about how we're going to spend
for those programs and we need to make a
statement right off that we had very
high taxes on the wealthy people
Roosevelt raised the top rate on the
federal income tax to 79 percent in 1935
in other words we're asking investors
this is a marginal rate the top rate to
give up four-fifths of all their income
past a certain level to invest in
companies and then we find lo and behold
they don't do it and Roosevelt is angry
and he builds his 1936 campaign against
these people and he said they hate me
and I welcome their hatred that's what
Roosevelt said during the campaign and
in 1937 you know we hear talk attacks
well Roosevelt cut spending and that was
no good first of all we need to make a
point it's true
after the 36 election in 237 we slightly
cut spending it was not big and we still
were running a big deficit why did we
cut spending slightly because we always
cut spending slightly after an election
Roosevelt had just been reelected
reelected so the WPA dropped in numbers
because we don't need those people
anymore so we did have sort of a drop in
spending but what we also have that is
not often mentioned is we
an unrestricted profits tax and special
tax on corporations we had Roosevelt
with encouraging to some extent
mandatory collective bargaining which is
going to take place and we're going to
get the unionization of the auto company
auto companies and others and we're
going to get a minimum wage law that's
passed which is with us today and that
minimum wage law is going to prevent
employers from hiring people who cannot
add enough value that the minimum wage
demands to hire them in their company
and that's going to contribute to
unemployment and then FDR turns the IRS
loose against people Andrew Mellon he
turned it loose against Moses Hannah
Berg Moses Annenberg edited the
Philadelphia Enquirer in the
Philadelphia Inquirer ran editorials
condemning Roosevelt
so what Annenberg discovers whoa the IRS
investigation is there he owes money he
goes to prison and then we find the
editor of the Philadelphia record who
was which was a democratic paper they're
getting a loan from Roosevelt the
reconstruction Finance Corporation for
somewhat the same amount is that is an
America was having to pay back in tax
liabilities and so now we have the
Democrats getting a subsidy the
Republican being put in prison on an IRS
investigation
Roosevelt then said in 1938 and
thirty-nine of Morgenthau we need to go
after all of these rich people with an
IRS investigation of Morgenthau said
well wait a minute here why do we do
that and Roosevelt said and I quote
because it can gain us 10 million votes
we condemn the rich we blame them for
not hiring people we go over to
unemployed people and say it's their
fault and then when they don't hire we
can blame them then that justify
starting a public works program from the
taxes which we're taking from them so
that they can't expand their factories
this is the heart of the New Deal and it
raises a question in the last one I want
to get at and then we'll take open this
up for questions and because we've had
this issue of what ends the Great
Depression yeah what ends the Great
Depression that's that's a tough one and
I don't want to pretend as though we
have absolute answers that there's
research still in
ress on this but i would like to say a
couple things you can't very well end a
depression you could ask dr. Wolfram
here on campus by building stuff and
bombing them people and and say that
that's getting you out of it a great
depression I really urge you to take
econ 105 and you'll get the full story
on that but let me give you the abridged
version you have here 12 million people
were sending overseas now that's good
and from an unemployment since that's
good because we had a little bit less
than that who are unemployed so we're
sending 12 million overseas and then we
have 12 to 15 million people working
then in the defense industry so I think
you can see therefore unemployment goes
way down by the way which is interesting
cuz the WPA for a while is still going
in the midst of this because Roosevelt
still had elections going on here and
but in any case put that aside
we've got 12 million people overseas in
the military we have 12 to 15 in defense
industries that's well and good but as
we've had pointed out by speakers
already the national debt then goes from
40 billion dollars to 260 billion so see
what we've in effect done is we've taken
all those people subsidized them while
they go dropping bombs on places and now
we have a debt of 260 billion we
increase the national debt by a by 6
fold in other words we started the war
with about 40 billion national debt then
we're up to 260 billion my goodness the
interest rate on the 260 billion is
almost as much as the whole national
debt was before that I mean not quite
it's that the debt was a little bit
higher than that but I mean it gets you
thinking my gosh this is a huge national
debt so we didn't solve the Great
Depression in fact the issue is what are
we gonna do after the boys come home and
many new dealers said hole we need a new
New Deal they call it the New Deal
revival we're gonna get a host of new
federal programs to bring them back they
were not successful
in fact they were distinctly
unsuccessful and you had and I quote
from Congress here senator Walter George
in October 24th 1945 talks about a bill
to cut tax rates to get us out of the
Great Depression he says you're right
we're gonna get into a great the drake
depression is gonna go on after the word
if we continue the New Deal he says
there are people out there want to
rebuild our stockpile of silver and so
he said we need tax cuts because that's
what we tried the 1920s when the top
rate was 25% and that is what worked
then Andrew Mellon said in the 1920s our
Secretary of Treasury in the 20s and I
quote it seems difficult for some to
understand that high rates of Taxation
do not necessarily mean large revenue to
the government and that war revenue may
often be obtained by lower rates in
other words he's saying if you cut the
rates it may in addition to encouraging
investment it may actually increase
revenue he was right on both counts
Calvin Coolidge had the lowest inflation
and unemployment rate of any president
of the 20th century we had budget
surpluses every year of the 1920s we
chopped off almost a third of the
national debt and we had senators who
remembered that in 1945 and said let's
go back to that and try that because the
spending stuff isn't working
here's what senator Walter George
another Democrat who had had been
enlightened on this issue and here's
what he says he's talking about this
bill to cut tax rates and I might add
just so I describe this bill
specifically it cut the big they cut the
income tax rate because after the war
the income tax rate was 94 percent on
top incomes so I was like cite to FDR
that six percent was money left on the
table you know but it was it was 94
percent on top incomes
the corporate rate was the top rate was
90% this bill was going to lower the the
top income tax rates um
but the big lowering was the corporate
rate because we're removing this excess
profits tax and we were cutting it from
ninety percent to thirty eight percent
as a top rate that was the proposal
Senator George says this this bill is
properly a tax rate reducing bill it
will not necessarily reduce the amount
of revenue coming in indeed if it has
the effect which is it is hoped it will
have it will so stimulate the expansion
of business as it to bring in a greater
total revenue I think if one will look
back to World War one he will understand
precisely what I am trying to say
senator from new jersey albert hawks who
was a businessman in the senate said
this the repeal of the excess profits
tax in my opinion may raise more revenue
for the united states than would be
raised if it were retained those bills
come into effect and indeed we do over a
period of three or four years see a
sharp increase in revenue to the
government but more than that we sent a
message to business people we're cutting
your taxes we want you to invest again
in the american economy and they did in
tremendous amounts and we had only three
point nine percent unemployment 1946 in
1947 the tax cuts i think played a big
role in getting us out of the Great
Depression now some people say well
you've dug this up and congressional
records you know how can people
understand and get at that well the
reason I have these quotations is they
were given to me by my research
assistant here at Hillsdale College Jim
des but who went home and over the break
and Cincinnati Ohio went into the
University of Cincinnati dug up this
information brings it in and now I'm
quoting it I think if Hillsdale students
can do it that my fellow historians can
do it too
I regret that the New Deal failed it was
an abysmal failure it sent us on the
wrong direction but we were able to
overcome pieces of it definitely and
that tax cut going into effect producing
more economic growth is a remarkable
example of that President Reagan is you
know President Kennedy even in the 60s
and then Reagan in the 80s also cut
taxes and they saw a tremendous economic
growth and a lowering of unemployment
and I would like to suggest not stimulus
packages and not priming the pumps with
WPAS and certainly not the Keynesian
argument that we absolutely need to have
vast public works but cutting taxes and
don't let central planners to train
presidents determine what politically
good districts they're going to send the
money into what business people and
American people invest startup
businesses expand existing ones put
people to work invent and develop
television and those things after the
war and send the American economy on a
prosperous route with relative freedom
and limited government thank you
thank you very much thank you I couldn't
have done it without senator George and
Senator Hawkes they're the ones who
deserve the ovations without them we
would not have good arguments and good
answers to this difficult question of
dealing with the Great Depression and
getting out thank you very much dr.
Folsom dr. volson will be available
after our questions for a book signing
in the lobby and his book New Deal or
raw deal will be available for purchase
thank you doctor Folsom um I just had
one question about the tax cuts you're
talking about Sean what was Roosevelt's
opinion on those did he support them or
was he against them the interesting
thing is he was against I mean he was in
the grave he always was against he was
always against tax cuts and he would
have opposed them he he never had a tax
cut he never never had a tax cut and he
his idea was that if you take this money
and you centralize it that he and other
central planners and others politicians
would be able to spend it and help the
American economy better than people
would be able to spend their own money
in effect that's his philosophy and so
he was not in favor of tax cuts he did
die before the end of the war and so he
didn't personally get involved which in
many ways was good because Truman was
not as good a manipulator as Roosevelt
and I say that to Truman's credit II
it's ruined is a very honest person he
agreed with Roosevelt but Truman would
be right honest with you you know he
wouldn't call up and say I like this
bill and if you don't like it I mean I
have an IRS investigation on you that
wasn't his approach and so he honestly
said well I'm just going to oppose this
and then the other senators favored it
and they passed it and it became the New
Deal horror story you know my mom
brought me up on was was the
confiscation of the gold do you have
anything to say about that episode my
grandfather father was very disappointed
that it didn't start a civil war
yeah I do talk about that in the book
all we could say is Roosevelt did indeed
confiscate gold he had to because he was
manipulating the currency in the price
of the currency if he had not
confiscated the gold if he didn't Flay
to the currency and the US had committed
to pay a certain price for gold people
would just take the inflated currency
and then buy doll and he couldn't have
that and so we had he felt he had to
take it it's a good example where you
try one intervention and it leads you to
have to do another intervention and
pretty soon you are really damaging
individual liberty and I think you see
that with the with the gold confiscation
and the whole us getting off the gold
standard yes well sure okay Tyler
reminded you of your class Tyler you
look so good in that beard aye aye well
anyway I don't want to take up people's
time with Jesse trace your speech
greatly I greatly enjoyed it
but there was one issue with the silver
the 42 tons was it forty two thousand
twenty two thousand tons right I had
never heard of that before and I'd be
very interested to know why where it
actually went and the details behind it
well I mean you have a point Tyler it's
not the sort of thing that Morgenthau
over and treasury could say well let's
just stop put this in the closet we had
a lot of it apparently at the mints in
San Francisco and in Denver and in
Philadelphia and apparently as I
understand it in Fort Knox we had some -
we had some in Washington I'm not sure
the various amounts it's a question I'm
interested in - because it's hard to
hide that quantity of silver
and by the way I devote divided
Roosevelt's programs into two categories
the bad programs and the worse
programs and I haven't even given you
the worst programs tonight the worst
programs have death rates such as his
attempt to say no the commercial
airlines are making obscene profits with
the with airmail travel so we'll take it
from them have the army deliver the mail
and then the army delivers the mail in
crash crash crash we have 12 pilots
killed then he says well let's go back
to having the airlines deliver the mail
the commercial you know we had those
programs that are in the mix - Tyler we
don't hear a lot about New Deal programs
I focused on the WPA and the triple-a
and the NRA though that's the heart of
the New Deal and I feel that's where the
battle ought to be fought rather than
going off on these side programs but I
just want you to know like the silver
effect if it's part of Roosevelt's
effort to be re-elected the silver fits
with the WPA their targeted subsidies to
special interests to get the votes to
get reelected dr. Paulson thank you very
much for your speech and I'd like to
hear something about contextualizing a
solution for today I mean our tax cuts
going to get us out of twenty trillion
dollars of debt is the rise of or the
problem North Korea the rise of Islam
China the tricky trade imbalance all of
these serious problems we're facing
today are they can they even be compared
do you have a do you have any idea of
what would be a good course even if it
may be difficult to accomplish in in the
coming years and last question is what
is your web address for campaign finance
spending
I'm not campaigning but I do have a blog
at Burt Folsom dot-com
and I try to apply history to current
events often with the New Deal
when I discuss contemporary issues so so
I do that at Burt Folsom doc.com
you're welcome to subscribe free I I'm
an optimist you know your question
implied pessimism and I think historians
oddly enough in some ways if they'll
think through it they tend to be
optimistic because every period that we
study if you read the newspapers and
contemporary accounts they wish like oh
my gosh this is a crisis it's
unsurmountable and and you see this
especially 1930 studying the New Deal
where people are just they say my gosh
it's up taxes at 90% look at all the
power this guy has look what he's doing
with the silver what he's doing with the
WPA the civilization is over and it
wasn't good ideas had a way of
prevailing they didn't prevail right
away but they did eventually we tried
tax cuts in the 1920s we had high
unemployment after World War one Harding
and Coolidge came in with Mellon and
there were people who wanted a stimulus
package then and they said no cut the
taxes they did and we went from 12%
unemployment in 1921 to 2 percent
unemployment two years later it was that
quick and the 20's ended up being a
great economic decade it looked hopeless
there in 1921 it wasn't later the
despair I see by many free-market
thinkers in the 1920 1930s is pitiful
and yet look what happened we get the
tax cuts pretty soon we go through the
1980s we get the rates down to 28% so I
mean here they were at 94% and now the
top rates at 28% in the 1980s we get
that then we have a boom another
historical example of giving people more
freedom produces more prosperity for
them the lesson proved again and so I'm
satisfied that the history one of the
things history helps us with is that
good ideas have a way of coming back and
being successful over time not right
away but over time and good ideas that
we've had in the past will be applied
again and we have people trying to do
that and therefore I believe we will see
an improvement in the situation economic
situation we have today
um I I was curious why does it seem like
so many academia and politicians ignore
these facts and what do you think the
best way to communicate these ideas is
yes the first question is one that
really is a why do so many academics
in for the for the for the you know what
we might call the liberal argument that
we need to spend a lot I think somewhat
I mean here yeah it's careful because I
don't want to get in people's heads it's
easier to describe what happened and
what the consequences are rather than
saying why are they doing what they're
doing
say which which puts you on a little
more speculative ground but I do know
that s you know being around academics
they don't like the idea that in free
markets an underwear salesman can earn
more than they do
and the truth is that that capital is
distributed in such a way that if you
can market products that have value it
gives it creates jobs and it creates
economic development and wealth for the
people who develop them and the idea
that no no we can plan the economy turn
it over to the experts who are highly
trained in economics and that they will
come in and tell us what to do will
produce better it's very compelling and
attractive to many academics and I and I
think that's that explains a lot of it
what we can do I mean we do what we can
do one thing that I that excites me
teaching here at Hillsdale College is
that we have a lot of people here who
really get it and they're gonna go out
there and I'm gonna be gone and and and
go off to my great reward and you guys
are still gonna be here and it gives me
pleasure to say hey I'm helping develop
the human capital as are many of my
colleagues in the history department
political science economics and other
places in the in the college here to
provide you with the information and the
evidence to fight this battle for the
next generation I had to fight it I'm a
baby boomer I had to fight the battle
and the issues that Roosevelt gave us
you know you sort of it's like you go
back and you fight the wars that the
last war the in the last war when I was
growing up was the FDR Warren you're
fighting that one and lo and behold it's
to say more that we're fighting now and
so these ideas of providing more freedom
and individual liberty freeing up the
economy and lowering taxes that that in
reducing regulations that that will
produce and help the economy more than
the high tax rate and the centralized
government that idea is alive and well
here at Hillsdale College I believe that
in the next generation there are people
at Hillsdale College that will be
fighting that battle and fighting it
very effectively
if I didn't believe that I wouldn't be
here but I do believe really curious it
was asserted earlier that in the 30s the
first countries to get out of the
depression were Germany Britain because
of the armament programs so I'm really
curious as to what your opinion is on
that well yes there are two points first
of all you're back - okay you're
building for defense some of that was
but then you have the question what do
you do when the war is over
say you're back then are you gonna argue
to use freedom or not are you gonna go
with high taxes the defense industry is
only a temporary measure until the war
is over because otherwise you get a
national debt that rises too high and
you go bankrupt you inflate the currency
it's worthless so you can't make it
completely on defense that that's not
going to work the second thing is
defense didn't become big in most
European countries except for Germany
until the later 1930s it's interesting
the League of Nations conducted data and
collected it on what countries had what
rates of unemployment and it's
interesting that when the United States
in 1938 had 20% unemployment which I've
been telling technically was not at that
time was 19.8 rounded off to 20% the
average that the League of Nations
collected for all the other European
nations was 11% most of that was not
through defense it was in Germany what
I'm telling you is the United States was
not only bad it was disproportionately
bad compared for the rest of the world
and that the question needs but needs to
be asked is why was the u.s. performance
distinctively bad against that of the
other nations of the world and that's
because our government programs were
more disastrous than their government
programs because we had the
undistributed corporate profits tax we
had all those IRS audits we had a
minimum wage law we had the discussion
of Social Security which is good because
we were collecting as Professor Brinkley
said we're collecting taxes on it all
throughout the late 30s but we're not
paying anything out that takes money out
of circulation we were doing
distinctively things bad that other
nations weren't doing
or cert hello sorry yes hi hi my name is
Sarah and I am a student from a school
in Southwest Michigan and I wanted to
say thank you for your presentation and
for all the other presentations we've
we've endured so far was really
wonderful sure I would like to ask the
question and that is I think it's very
easy for us to look back 60 years ago
and make all these claims of what FDR
and the New Deal did wrong and we have
all of this knowledge and this amazing
retrospective perspective but I want to
know if the historian I'm sorry if the
conservative politicians of that day
we're thinking the same things that
we're thinking today yeah good question
some were in some weren't there were
some who had it figured and many who
didn't but the main thing were the ones
who opposed him who tended to be in the
Republican Party we're getting tossed
out of office left and right because
with these subsidies see the Republicans
were down to 88 seats in the house and
that means the Democrats had what 360
roughly and so when you're losing seats
at that proportion a lot of more having
to think and I understand this you know
politicians have to be re-elected they
can have good ideas but if they go out
of office with those ideas not
implemented their success is is not
great even though they may have advanced
an idea they need to be around to
accomplish it we just simply didn't have
too many people who were opposing
Roosevelt who were able to hang on to
office and so that was part of the
problem I do want to say too and I want
to give Roosevelt some credit he did
reduce the tariff rates from that
smoot-hawley Tariff with the reciprocal
tariff act he at Cornell Hall as
Secretary of State had the authority to
do some nation-to-nation reducing in
that aisle so I mean we did have a
couple things here and there that were
useful but by and large it was not it
was harmful and it was hard for
politicians to oppose it because you
start opposing it the next thing you
know you're running against a candidate
who's just been given huge subsidies to
run against you and he's promising if
he's elected he'll bring projects into
that district and you're sitting there
saying no we ought to do it privately
and you are in a tough reelection
campaign and this is the
dilemma that those who opposed Franklin
Roosevelt had then and it's the dilemma
that those who propose big government
have today as well just a reminder that
dr. Poulsen will be available for a book
signing after questions and we thank you
dr. Folsom talk was great
thank you I won't be able to cut your
class but I know my brother will he's a
history major I had a question for you I
grew up in rural Indiana on a farm and
my grandpa started our farm but he grew
up in the Great Depression and basically
the way he describes it as you know
after 1929 the prices of grain and
things just fell off the face of the
earth you know and they were reduced to
eating you know he basically just hate
cabbage and things like that he still
wouldn't touch cabbage when I knew him
he hated the thing so my question is for
you is um
times were bad and a lot of farmers were
losing their farms and yeah the Triple A
might not have been a good solution but
what what would be a proactive solution
to solve that problem during that time
because people are suffering and they
are losing their farms and just losing
everything they have and obviously that
isn't good and a lot of free market
people would say that's the flow of the
system but is there a more proactive
solution that you would be in favor of
yeah I mean obviously paying farmers not
to produce and building a mountain of
silver isn't through I won but I
nonetheless you asked a good question
you say well what sorts of things can we
do one of the reasons I like the idea of
relative freedom is that that answers
the question in free markets for example
we have problem with overproduction of
goods and low prices we have people move
off the lands and into the cities
historically you know we after all in
our first census we had over 80 percent
of Americans were farmers either
primarily or at least partly were
farmers and we had that reduce substan
to maybe 20 25 percent in the 1930s and
it's down to less than 1% today and so
we've been able to pick up those people
in the industrial sector the reason we
couldn't do it in the 30s of course is
because we had such high taxes that we
had businessman and we had the tariffs
and we had the Federal Reserve those
those bad solutions which were some of
which were unique to the 1930s which is
why we didn't have depressions that
severe before and so the secret is if
you can get rid of those you can get the
tariffs down and I gave Roosevelt some
credit he was working in that direction
but then if you can get the Federal
Reserve working for working in a
different way and get the tax rates down
then you free people up then you have a
bigger demand for foreign products
because now you can export your farm say
25 percent of American exports our farm
of farm products are exported well when
we have a small amount like tariffs and
nobody's buying our farm products we
can't export anymore
you take the tariffs down and you get a
freer trade system then they get to
export so I'm saying if when you ask
that question you have to look at it
from a standpoint of a lot of things are
being done that are bad and you've got
to start taking them off one by one
freeing people up and I do want to add
this when we had our first welfare
system that went into effect the first
relief system in 1932 and it lasted 233
it was 300 million dollars
we did have Massachusetts Connecticut
and six states that said we're not gonna
take this federal aid and get tied into
this kind of life we're gonna supply it
locally even in times of 25%
unemployment you still had states that
were able to manage their own relief and
they do it I mean in the case of
Massachusetts they had exhibition
football games between two of the
colleges there they had the Boston
Symphony playing for charities they had
wealthy people giving food and in free
landlines for people they had teachers
I'm really proud of this teachers gave
up about 2% of their salary for relief
measures to help the people of
Massachusetts the kind the founders
wanted local wanted people to help
people and more people could have helped
more people if we wouldn't have been
hampered by so many restrictions in the
1930s